hello everyone and welcome to a
beautiful game from the tal Memorial of
2018 it was the Blitz game and it's a
game between Daniel dubov and
vishwanathan Anan now if you're
wondering why I'm out of the blue just
showing a game between Daniel dubo and
vishwanathan Ananda it's because today
fide published this on their Twitter
profile they said that now the
commentators for the World Chess
Championship match between Ed England
and Yani ponishi are known and the
commentators will be abhishman Ananda
Daniel dubov and Irina Crush now Anand
will be commentating uh from uh game one
to four dubo will be commentating uh up
until the the last game of the match if
if it's gonna go into Rapids and uh you
know all the way Andy Arena will be
commentating with both with Anand and
with Daniel throughout the entire match
now I thought um okay that's a very
interesting tweet but uh Then I then I
uh started wondering has uh how many
times has dubov faced Anand uh and what
are their head-to-head scores and they
they've only faced each other once in
2020 Tata still Masters in the In
classical time format but they have
played quite a few Blitz and Rapid games
and the total score is seven to one uh
for for Daniel dubo and I've already
shown one game between the two of them
it's uh from the grand Chester uh in
2020. uh if you haven't seen it do check
it out really features a wonderful line
it will be the first link in the
description below so maybe you want to
check out that game before checking out
this one or you can check out this one
and then check out that one as both of
them are quite nice but this one like I
said it's from the Tom Memorial 2018 and
the game is uh particularly spectacular
because of a line that was not played
and since this is a Blitz game I don't
see it possible to even calculate such a
line in a Blitz game but you guys are
comfortable in your in your own homes
maybe driving a car maybe waiting at the
airport and you will have all the time
in the world uh to calculate such a such
a crazy line so let's dive straight into
it Daniel has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to C4
uh he starts with the English opening
with E5 by Anand Knight to C3 and the
bishop to B4 going for the comic Shield
of counter attack Knights the D5 now
attacks the bishop and pawn to A5 black
doesn't mind the doubling up the B
points as this will open up the the da
file for The Rook so Knight to F3
ignoring that we have Pawn to D6 and
pawn to G3 now I agree getting ready to
fin Kettle the light Square Bishop we
have C6 and Knight goes back to E3 we
have Knight to F6 and now Bishop to G2
Castles by both sides and now comes Rook
to E8 so now you can push D5 as the E5
Pawn will be nicely protected D4 Daniel
strikes in the center e captures on D4
Knight captures on D4 and now there is a
game where Knight B to D7 was played but
here we have Knight to A6 and it is now
as of move tender we have a completely
new game that's okay this uh here Knight
looks a little bit weird so Daniel has
to figure out a way how to improve the
position of his Knight and then maybe do
something about the E2 Pawn Knight E
back the seat you now puts pressure on
the bishop Bishop to C5 and now Pawn to
B3 now the bishop can be uh shifted over
to this beautiful diagonal Knights the
B4 and now Bishop to B2 we have Bishop
to G4 by Anand making it hard for uh
Daniel to advance his E Pawn and now uh
just bringing the Knight back to E3
Knight to E3 goes after the bishop
Bishop to H5 and now Pawn to A3 kicking
away the Knight Knight the A6 and now
Knight D to F5 it's a beautiful Square
for the Knight and also puts um constant
pressure on that G7 Pawn if the Knight
moves You're Gonna Lose That G7 Pawn so
Bishop to G6 it's a very nice Defender
and also anand's Bishop's pair is now
most certainly fully operational uh and
here
uh it's very hard to find the move for
for Daniel if you ask the engine the
engine will give you some weird moves
like Queen T1 you should play this for
Bishop to F3 or Bishop to H3 okay maybe
Definitely Maybe there are moves you
consider but um uh you know to play them
in a Blitz game not very likely So
Daniel goes for a move that you would
expect from Daniel and that is Knight
captures on G7 he opens up the attack
now opens up this diagonal and uh you
know that now Anand will have to defend
for a very long time so okay King
captures on G7 and now Knight to G4
continuing to put pressure on that F6
Knight and now just Rook the E6 and on
the defense uh you could also defend
with Rook D5 probably even a little bit
better because now you you're kind of
forcing white to recapture immediately
by playing Rook to E6 you're allowing do
both to improve his game a little bit so
here he starts with B4 uh dubo always
played B plays B4 if you allow it he
will find it and he will play it and
here it is a great move a character
zombie for a captures on B4 and now
Knight captures on B4 Bishop captures on
B4 is also very nice the idea was after
Bishop B4 Queen B3 will put pressure on
B7 for example Bishop goes back you're
gonna trade once on F6 Rook captures and
now Queen captures on B7 having pressure
along this diagonal and also putting
pressure on the Knight on A6 will
probably Rook to A7 the only good move
for black you're gonna move the queen
back and the game continues it's a
really wild position especially for
blitz so after a captures on B4 Anand
instead went for Knight capture some B4
and now Rook captures an A8 we have
Queen captures on E8 and now Doom of
plays this tricky Queen to d2 move Now
sort of eyeing that H6 square but now
the the question is how do you defend
this with uh with black can you find a
move for Anand here that actually holds
the position it's not easy and I believe
it is impossible to play such a move in
a Blitz game so feel free to pause the
video and try to find a defensive
resource for Anand while I give you a
couple seconds and enjoy this magical
line
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sporting this
uh I don't think we've had such a
complicated line ever and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to d8 uh certainly a move a lot
of you have considered about what
happens next is if you consider that
then you are truly a grand master
material maybe even super Grand Master
material uh Queen to H6 would check what
happens after Queen to H6 with the check
well the problem is King to G8 Knight
captures an F6 which check Rook captures
an F6 and now the the question is why
why did we do this why is the white even
trying this because white is now done a
piece white is down a full night the
point is Pawn to G4 and how are you
defending against Pawn to G5 you will
not be able to move the Rook because
Queen to G7 will be Checkmate this is
how you do it Knight the C2 an odd move
to play uh in expectance of G5 to happen
but that's exactly what you have to do
pawn to G5 and it seems like it's all
over You're Gonna Lose The Rook Bishop
capture then you're going to get
checkmated or if you move the Rook then
Queen G7 is Checkmate right away this is
the move that was hard to find when you
spotted Queen to d8 and that is Bishop
to E3 now uh it looks like a a terrible
movie it's like you know you just spit
in someone's face this bishop T3 move
but if you look at it you cannot play
Pawn captures on F6 because Bishop
captures an H6 on the other hand if you
play F captures on E3 then The Rook can
now move because Rook captures an F1
comes with Tempo Rook captures an F1
check and after uh bishop or King
characters you will play Queen to f8
again defending Checkmate and you have
you know avoided a disaster sorry not
that so what you would have to do after
this bishop to E3 move is play something
like Bishop to F3 now you are
threatening to capture the bishop
because the Rook will not be able to
capture Rook there's a bishop in between
but now you play Knight to D for you
block the bishop and again The Rook can
move and you cannot capture The Rook
because of Bishop captures on H6 but
okay now you play F characters and E3
this is not possible but now you play
Rook captures on F3 again moving The
Rook is possible because the bishop is
blocked now Rook captures an F3 and
Knight captures an F3 with check e
captures an F3 and now Queen to fade you
defend against Checkmate it's equal
material and while your position is uh a
little bit difficult to play you should
be able to survive and not not get the
checkmated and you know probably draw
the game so that was definitely in the
position and this is uh why why the game
is so spectacular but Anand did not find
it he played King to f8 and now dubo
just uh goes all out here Knight
captures on F6 uh you you cannot
recapture because the bishop defends we
have Queen to d8 uh interestingly
unplays it but only on the second move
and now Queen to H6 with check King to
E7 and now Bishop to F3 Bishop to H3
also possible for some reason dubov
prefers to play F3 to G4 Knight to C2
and now we have Queen to H for
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries here and you can't really
uh move the king if you play King to f8
then we're gonna capture an H on H7 now
the queen is hanging so you have to go
back then the Knight Returns Knight to
F6 with checking to f8 and Bishop to G4
which was the plan all along so Anand
instead went for Queen to A5 he moves
the queen uh away uh so now he might be
able to escape to the queen side via the
d8 square but now Knight characters on
H7 would check not allowing this and
also uh you can't really go to D7
because of Knight to f8 to check
connects nicely with the Rook here so
King the E8 was played but now just
Knight to F6 with check King to d8 and
now Bishop to G4 going after the rook
and The Rook has no uh no squares here
uh we have King to C7 trying to escape
but not just Bishop captures on E6 we
have F captors and E6 and queen to H6
and he was in this position on move 31
that uh vishwanathan Anand resigned in
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here once uh you you save the
bishop your Bishop is attacked just
let's say Pawn to G4 and athletic winter
B4 goes after the bishop you're just
gonna capture capture captures and
captures and you are down the exchange
and also you have the uh to worry about
the past E Pawn the black king is wide
in the open and all of Black's forces
are on the queen side the king is uh
safe safe on G1 on the king side so
there's really no no way of even putting
pressure on White's position here so
that's why Anand resigned after uh Queen
to H6 and another great victory for
Daniel Duo but this line here uh that
we've discussed if Anan founded the
queen to the eighth move that actually
holds this position uh is a definitely
one of the craziest lines I've seen in a
while and we've seen a couple of crazy
lines in the in the past month uh so
yeah like I said if you haven't seen the
one from the creation Grand Chester
between Daniel and Anand it's it's
really a remarkable game to check it out
first link in the description below I'm
sure you guys will enjoy that as well
and yeah I hope you enjoyed that little
bit of info about the commentating theme
during the the a wheelchair championship
match in Astana Kazakhstan between
should be should be a wild one even
though uh I I can't really remember but
uh for the last few uh World Chase
Championship matches here at vulgar was
doing the commenting uh now she isn't uh
I have no idea why that is maybe she
just declined or maybe they didn't
invite her once I uh learn I'm
definitely gonna inform you of this uh
but no doubt Ileana Crush will do will
do a wonderful job as you've seen how
strong she is uh in the in the American
Cup that she won without losing a single
classical game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh uh I've been told you guys
always enjoy a nice dupe game I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
nishad uh who turns nine today I hope
you have a great day and this is the
perfect age to start studying the end
game and I would like to thank Henry
Spraggins Richard carp Laurent Andre
ignacini and the ravishing reptiles
YouTube for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day